comment peut-on être montagne alors
c'est une question qui peut vous
semblera très simple trépidant sereine
ali peut-être pas de quoi parler pendant
un quart d'heure sur une question comme
celle là j'ai essayé de vous montrer
contraire la question elle est pas si
simple et si naïve que ça musulmans elle
mérite qu'on y réfléchisse à deux fois
trois fois mais peut-être et j'aimerais
vous montre également que avec cette
question on peut aussi réfléchir à nos
sociétés et nos fonctionnements de
société aujourd'hui et la façon qu'on a
de construire les identités collectives
de contrer les identités politiques de
se définir actuellement le crédit moins
que c'est un très gros enjeu c'était
contemporaine alors pour commencer puis
vous faire prendre conscience peut être
caractère pas si naïf de cette question
j'en ai et non pas trois questions que
j'ai trois les mancelles vous proposer
je veux que notre participation
que vous utilisiez et non 6 après
l'annoncé ils vont apparaître sur
l'écran
si vous êtes d'accord pas d'accord avec
cet énoncé je vous demande simplement de
lever la main si vous êtes d'accord
alimenta lien par son habitat en
montagne est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec sa voix la moitié peut pas remonter
pas suffisant ok une deuxième façon de
dire au nom tania par son élève en
paille et aux pratiques à l'antenne qui
sera d'accord avec ça davantage bien
merci et 3e énoncés on y re baignade
pendant ma vie
- le bras mais par contre avec l'élan au
calme merci alors il faut surprendre ses
toiles énoncés qui sont tout à fait
anodin au premier abord et qui ne sont
pas en fait parce que ça correspond au
a3 façon de définir le montagnard de
sentiers montagnards et je vais vous
montrer que ces trois façons dont une
histoire et une actualité jeu commencera
le 1er on est montagne 1 quand on habite
en montagne l'une et 95 de l'assistance
à dire que vous étiez d'accord avec cet
énoncé est ce que c'est si simple que ça
devient des chaussons art
ça suppose d'abord de se mettre d'accord
sur ce qu'est une montagne et ses
suppôts se mettent d'accord sur l'idée
que parce qu'il ya des montagnes et des
gens dans les montagnes ces gens-là du
risque d'être âpre et des montagnards
formulation bien compliqué pour une
lignée qui vous paraît très simple
l'hépatite simple que ça elle a une
histoire on est habitué à cette
formulation la [ __ ] l'histoire que je
vous racontais rapidement d'abord se
mettre d'accord sur ce que c'est qu'une
montagne vous le savez peut-être on
parle de montagne et en quantité
contexte parcours différents il ya des
endroits dans le monde où on parle de
montagne alors que pour vous c'est
peut-être pas des montagnes ou peut-être
plus des montagnes à l'est de l'île de
france par exemple en champagne en
france vous avez un vaudois de plateau
ce qu'on a eu une presta quand on le
joue en pologne on appelle la montagne
de reims
et puis c'est aussi un parc naturel
régional et pour les rémois pour les
électeurs de la ville de reims c'est une
montagne parce que ça s'appelle la
montagne de reims pour des la légende
explique tout et vous veillez tout à
fait d'accord avec l'énoncé le jazz à
montréal au centre de la ville de
montréal vous avez ce qu'on appelle
maintenant une grosse collines et les
montréalais se plaisent à appeler la
montagne et le très longtemps du xviie
siècle ou bien à paris vous avez le
m'embarrasse vous avez eu montmartre et
puis deux juments l'art la photographie
est ici depuis montmartre vous avez
quelque chose qui pourrait prendre le
cat il a faim qu'on appelle la montagne
sainte geneviève est ce que pour autant
les étudiants qui vont à la sorbonne ou
bien les gens qui font les bruits les
magasins où ils resteront en prison
790 alliance tout simplement parce que à
l'instar montréal à paris on appelle
cela des montagnes partout dans le monde
donc il a fallu ce n'était pas sur les
définitions de la montagne et la
définition de la montagne qu'on a
aujourd'hui un peu sourd j'aurais fait
le fait son calcul scientifique sont
tombés d'accord sur gifi fondamental
aujourd'hui mais en tout cas dans nos
représentations collectives les
déconseille d'avant d'alice est
essentiellement des perles heureux avec
une définition il ya l'attitude et
éventuellement au volume de la montagne
et même au milieu écologique et la carac
arrive et c'est une définition qui
apparaît au xviiie siècle aussi belle et
lumière à la faveur du travail et qu'en
france les spécialistes d'histoire
naturelle et il a fallu attendre les
leurs que ma fille en particulier et
notamment elle reste partie de détail
comme celle ci les planches charte
graphique qui dépendent d'un état ce qui
a été réalisé à la fin du xviiie siècle
à l'échelle de tout le monde au mois
donc où les haltes commence à prendre de
l'épaisseur commence à devenir une sorte
de milieux naturels indique de région
dans lequel on imagine volontiers qu'il
perd des habitants qui sont en rapport
avec la montagne correspondante
parce que les naturalistes et les hommes
les femmes des philosophes et sa banque
xviiie siècle je pense la nature dans
les rapports avec les habitants qui
habitent cette même nature
donc on a inventé l'expression
montagnards quand on s'est mis d'accord
la retraite société les montagnes et
quand on a pensé que les individus que
nous en cette règle est en forte
relation avec leur milieu naturel
donc le monde l'expression a son
histoire une histoire scientifique mise
par sa vente
une histoire philosophique et du coup on
a commencé à voir avec une
caractérisation extrêmement stéréotypé
dans un premier vingt désarmement tania
ici vous avez les trois images aligné
dix sont prises du mali stage dans une
page d'index ouvrages de vulgarisation
géographique qui présente les grands
milieux naturels et la diversité des
populations du monde et les montagnes 1
sont représentés cette façon-là a montré
nardelli malaga
locale un guide alpin voilà trois
stéréotypes qui s'installent des xviiie
siècle qui se stabilise au 19e siècle et
par lesquels on a commencé à penser les
montagnards toujours dans leurs rapports
avec la montagne naturelle avec le
climat avec la pente
elles étaient contraintes du milieu
c'était la façon de penser les choses au
xviiie siècle et s'est pas limitée comme
vous l'avez compris avec le caucase et
du malien uniquement à nos régions nous
met dans le cadre de la colonisation des
dons ci également a caractérisé les
populations des hauts plateaux de
montagnards quelle que soit celle qui
était la façon qu'ils allaient le même
de ceux désignés par exemple du
colonisateur français l'administration
coloniale française en indochine a pris
l'habitude d'appeler toutes les
populations extrêmement diverses ils
n'ont rien à voir les unes avec les
autres entament de langue de culture de
religion des moteurs de la machine
damon de l'union mené par le français
sam au viet à l'homme viet et la langue
du vietnam aujourd'hui est une langue
des plaines cd diète qui avait pris
l'habitude de qualifier comme ces
populations qui ne connaissaient pas de
boy
il conserve repris l'expression la
personne qui dans ses auteurs
aujourd'hui s'appelle maurice se définit
comme étant moi même
onlive au paiement de cette
caractérisation un petit peu
scientifique et savante je parlais déjà
tout à l'heure de stéréotypes la
philosophie le tourisme la littérature
touristiques ont multiplié les images de
caractérisation morale psychiquement
balles d'armes seulement n'était censé
être de son milieu naturel et devait
être aussi marqué dans son âme dans ses
notes de penser par la montagne
environnante et donc les stéréotypes
dont continue à apparaître a surgi et
vous les connaissez tous en bas à droite
julie d'analysé l'amoureuse de sa creux
le dépressif genevois la maison de ville
comme on dit
à l'époque et qui va sauver 5 rue de sa
dépression en lisant découvrez les
charmes de la montagne de l'amour et de
la simplicité
julie est l'incarnation de la bonne
sauvage et que rousseau la préconisent
ou la vente dans sa philosophie a levé à
l'opposé le cred un visage beaucoup de
montagne à rédiger de crétins moment ou
un autre entre dans les alpes entre
trente années je suis désolé entre dans
22 centres dans notre savoir dans sa
voix brèche le crétin fait partie de ces
stéréotypes montagnards c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui est marqué par la
compagnie au prix dans son intellect
avant qu'on découvre et on était d'abord
et en traitant la cause de la
consanguinité qui frappait les
populations demandent à l'ue comme les
populations insulaires et surtout
surtout les familles royales d'europe
mais ça l est pas dire combien de l'idée
au champagne qui était vertueux
extrêmement habile dans la fréquentation
de la montagne paraît vital sur le mode
génétique a pas s'il avait un prix parce
qu'il est elle davantage toujours appris
à gravir les montagnes
donc vous voyez que je suis en train de
dériver la caractérisation qui se veut
savante je réalise berne stéréotypes
sociaux philosophique allège une
dimension les règlements politiques
le montagnard le team bon sauvage move
est un peu d'esprit voire un problème le
montagnard devient un problème en suisse
à la fin du xvie siècle mais aussi en
france en autriche en espagne
à l'époque des grandes inondations vous
avez vous entendu parler plus la légende
entre vous parce que ça concerne l'euro
de particuliers mais aussi des grandes
villes
leïla pin et ces inondations mais ça
l'est peut-être ont été attribués à
l'inconscience des entraîneurs qui
déboisent et sur pattes you make me des
déchets partout et même temps partout en
france alors interdit on a commencé à
mettre en place des politiques
forestières et le montagnard a été
stigmatisée comme étant le fauteur de
trouble le problème véritablement de la
gestion forestière et hydrauliques dans
les alpes dans les pyrénées ici une
image extraite d'un petit ouvrage de
vulgarisation justement qui fait la
promotion de supplétifs forestière vous
avez l'animal un berger justement une
phrase heureux de sa condition et un
troupeau un objectif ou à lyon pour un
visage au dessus du mot désolé
le commentaire de l'image triste hauteur
de sa propre ruine duneton lui semble
réclamer l'air
absente on voit les graisses les arbres
brûlés par les derniers incendies dans
son inconscience il a lui même allumé
c'est le montagnard et volontiers
stigmatiser bien sûr il est loué par des
gens comme rousseau mais la plupart du
temps au 19e siècle
il est stigmatisé et encore beaucoup
moins sur d'autres pays comme la france
où comme images cd première énoncée ok
sa femme l'autre jouant à annuler le
montagnard comme étant encore une fois
ce qui est défini par la montagne un peu
à son insu parce qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude à ce moment là dans les
campagnes dans les bacs montagne de se
définir comme montagnards on est là les
ambiani par l'onu la montagne deuxième
façon de faire on est montagne 1 parce
qu'on est des montagnes on pratique la
montagne les une majorité ajoute ce
trailer est énoncé c'est très très
récent c'est très récent commence à bord
apparaissent cette façon de faire
uniquement au milieu du 19e siècle je
reviens sur cette photo et je dois
extrêmement intéressante où vous avez le
fameux crétin des alpes problématique
alors rassurez vous il ya des balises en
cellule avec le chinois mais vous voyez
bien que non seulement sur la photo que
j'avais également la ministre
blu ray vous avez un photographe lui
même ministre cette photographie est une
superbe façon de mettre en scène se
différencier social qu'on introduit au
début du 20e siècle
la photo date des années 1920 où il y à
une nouvelle catégorie personnes les
administrent kim ont commencé à être des
montagnards c'est nous lui c'est nous ac
nous on sait gravir la montagne à celui
qu'on la connaît la montagne le cas
échéant partie de clubs alpins et on
construit une connaissance sur la
montagne mont intervient sur les
décisions politiques des états sur le
devenir de la montagne une des personnes
qui a joué le plus grand rôle dans la
construction de cette image du
montagnard alpinistes c'est les barbus
peur ni les tous entendu parler
notamment cette année des centaines
canton de l'ascension du cervin le
premier quart d'heure à leur arrivée au
sommet du cervin où il pleuvra le plus
grand mépris pour les populations
montagne et quelques geeks y trouver
grâce à ses yeux à zermatt et chamonix
les appris hier et puis pour ratisser
les alsh et la quantité de première mais
il reste un très grand mépris pour les
montagnards y compris pour la plupart
des guides qu'elle sillonnait aussi
conclu
sur le fond oui meurt à revendiquer
l'appellation montagnards l'identité
montagne comme beaucoup d'autres listes
a les poches est une illustration de
cette revendication identitaire c'est la
tombe qu'il a choisi d'avoir oui mais
avec myriam unis et le premier dans
l'histoire des monuments funéraires à
choisir un monument funéraire de ce type
là un monstre les aiguilles de chamonix
en guise ou en lieu et place d'une stèle
du classique qui marquait encore une
fois le souci d'exister sur le long
terme de la casse à mort comme étant un
vrai montagne un troisième danser sur
lequel vous avez prononcé une minorité
montagnards parce qu'on est suisse là
aussi c'est une image qui est très
partagée en suisse est très partagée à
lyon dans le monde
le fait d'être suisse semble devoir
venir chacun des suisses comme étant des
montagnes installe dans cette histoire
et tous les titres des artistes des
philosophes année six semaines et il
avait figé lebrun une porte et triste
portrait disparus s'élève au xviiie
siècle réalisé ce tableau qui représente
deux premières têtes connues au début du
19e siècle et à contribuer avec beaucoup
claude rousseau notamment à forger le
mythe du montagnard démocratie et son
autonomie
bref le petit modèle la démocratie
européenne
on cherche à grandir et à l'époque et
jules loin tous les suisses sombrent et
montagne un de ceux qui placent sont
tous des gens delebarre lendemain moi
une façon aucune autre et la suisse
elle-même s'est emparé de cette image en
reproduisant une iconographie de la
montagne mise au service de la
célébration de cette institution
politique la presse jim nombre au palais
fédéral ou bien eu culte si les volets
civil assure de guillaume tell et les
façon générale de la montagne dans le
jeu explique nationale ou les
expositions ligne elle seule la suisse
est pas la seule à l'avoir fait
elle a fait école j'ai fait pas mal de
villes du monde notamment les gosses ont
laissé que deux ans et en a vraiment
marre des anglais ils ont commencé à se
définir au milieu du 19e siècle de
m'étendre des montagnes 1 c'est à dire
que les gens qui avaient à la portée des
choses
mais eux n'avaient pas vous voyez donc
avec les trois façons les poils dénoncé
que je vous ai donné son départ à 115
cantalien de façon extrêmement
différence sur le mode d'une entité
sociale on est y être montagnards de
loin par le ruisseau parle d'autre part
il avait touché leurs seins identité
personnelle et collective je me sens
dans tanière et je me sens montagnards
aussi montaner que les personnes qui se
disent dans ta lien donc une définition
personnelle intrinsèque je le veux et
identité politique est déjà présente et
club alpin qui veulent décider pour les
autres
les montagnards mauvais gestionnaires
des pâturages qui sont stigmatisés
ou bien imaginaire national et éthique
ou écossais qui célèbre du match de la
montagne ces trois formes d'identité
tourner ensemble elles se sont alimentés
et j'ai eu les autres et elles se sont
renforcées dans une sorte de spirale qui
réconforte chacune de ces identités
une façon comme une autre j'aimerais
vous montrer que tout se passe
extrêmement extrêmement actuelle est
aujourd'hui plus politique que jamais
parce que dans un monde très
interconnecter les aînés qui sont les
nôtres 13 à terrebonne et es13
européaniser très mondialisé la façon
que chacun d'entre nous avant de vous
souvenir avec la montagne donner autre
chose
elle joue un rôle de plus en plus
important dans notre façon de d'exister
dans l'espace public et de contribuer au
débat donc j'ai posé très vite la
question de savoir non plus qu'est ce
que c'est que la montagne ça en laisse
sound strike mais qu'est ce que c'est
d'être montagnard et qu'est ce que ça
veut dire politiquement deuxième je suis
mentalement nous sommes les montagnards
sont tendus que vous ne l'est pas
évidemment vous comprenez que quand on
dit nous sommes les montagnes à sabugal
que nous avons le droit de faire ce que
nous voulons nos montagnes qui paie
discours que vous connaissez bien en
suisse
à l'est en particulier les dernières
mutations de cette année a donné on fait
que les valaisans et les élus politiques
du valais ont beaucoup utilisé cette
rhétorique nous sommes du montagnard et
l'on sait ce qu'il faut faire les
quelques choses secondaires voit les
aménagements du territoire
c'est pas très vieux mais ça remonte à
quelques décennies ça commence en suisse
à nouveau dans les années 20 quand
vraiment les hôteliers les restaurateurs
les prestataires de services
touristiques
montagne commence à dire laisser ou
faire le développement touristique dans
les alpes
il commence à se dire montagnards
uniquement dans les années 1920 avant
personne d'utiliser l'appellation sauf
les alpinistes
c'est à dire d'autre les années 1940 le
syndicat des paysans de montagne
finalisant suisse et puis une
association équivalente en italie dans
les années 50 et 80 dans les années 90
une organisation comparable à celle de
l'union européenne à la montagne devient
un objet de ménagement du territoire de
l'union européenne vous avez été mon
talent bien trempée qui se fédèrent et
qui se reconnaissent à venir cette
appellation et plus récemment encore et
ça c'est tout à fait spectaculaire
depuis le sommet de la terre en 1992 à
côté du paiement la conférence de rio en
complément si l'environnement et
développement on commence à avoir un
vrai souci au niveau national ce sont
les montagnes quand il faut les gérer
globalement pour pouvoir qu'ils aient le
goût durable dans les régions de
montagne
l'agenda 21 les documents qui sort de la
conférence 2011 j'ai mis très spécifique
pour la première fois de l'histoire des
grandes conférences internationales
dédiées à la montagne et dans la foulée
on décide de créer une alliance à la cie
ne l'aiment de la montagne que vous
allez soutenir c'est en 2002 beaucoup de
choses se sont passées en valais sellal
et l'art et autres aussitôt après
surgit mais une association et pouvaient
être seulement d'un immonde alsatiques
de français et d'italien les portes et
vous avez dans cette association des
gens qui sont dans des montagnes
extrêmement variés de la planète qui
parlent pas la même langue qui ont pas
les mêmes cultures pas la même religion
tandis qu'il comprenne très peu mais qui
ont jugé utile de se mettre ensemble
pour peser sur les discussions
internationales négocier les choses avec
domination internationale
bref elle présente dans le débat
politique
illustration langage de terminale s a
illustré sur le calme cette
mondialisation des identités montagnards
qui sont revendiquées c'est l'élément
culturel qui l ue qui allaient que je
sais pas s'il existe un problème tous
les deux ans le ciment qui sont telles
que journée de commémoration que le
cheval sur les folklores montagne à
l'assemblée comme ça ils voteraient
j'entends vous voyez ici théâtre apollo
des actes slovène qui réunit l'espagnol
pour célébrer tous ensemble le fait
d'être montagnards un contexte européen
donc voilà une illustration de cette
européanisation pour monia lisa sion et
zurich
antalya conclusions morale de l'histoire
si vous voulez être montagnards c'est
pas si facile de définir ce qu'est un
montagnard comment peut-on être
montagnards il ya plusieurs façons de
l'allée compris deux des filiales cette
façon là mais c'est de plus en plus
politique s'allonge de plus en plus
politique et c'est pas du tout le propre
de la montagne vous savez tout ce qu'on
parle de plus en plus d'identité
identité collective entité politique en
se positionne tous est de plus en plus
sur un maul identitaire parmi ces
stations de construire que l'identité
collective
il ya des ressources qui sont liés au
paysage aux types de milieux politiques
d'environnement et chacun d'entre nous
est amené un moment ou un autre à se
définir de telle ou telle façon
géographiquement en plus le groupe
professionnellement ce genre de choses
et intervenir fin du match épique au
long de ces partis politiques je vous
remercie